is there anything so perfect as dogs in
the wind the way their cheeks deploy
like little parachutes I mean dogs cool
themselves by breathing through their
mouths so this must be literally the
most refreshing sensation the dog could
ever have but it seems like you can't
fake the experience for them and the
harder you try the more they'll resist
and you'll either make them really upset
or leave them too confused to carry on
because this is an unparalleled level of
animal bliss not even a cat getting a
suctioned head massage or a turtle doing
jazz hands at another turtle or two cows
just going to town none of these
sensations are nearly as freeing as
jowls flopping endlessly and when a dog
isn't in the wind he looks like he's
just wondering is it something I did
animals are always seeking new
experiences and some experiences are
romantic others are unpleasant and some
well some just speak for themselves but
nothing matches this majesty so what are
you waiting for go on get your best
friend in your car roll down the windows
and get ready to experience the absolute
perfection of dogs in the wind
I got to admit that horse with the tree
that's a close second